alice bob charles yvon à la mine pour
ramener une caisse de lingots d'or
cette caisse ne possède que deux
poignées une à gauche une à droite
le problème c'est qu'il faut absolument
être gaucher pour porter la poignée de
droite et seuls
alice est gauchère du coup alice porte
tout seul un côté de la caisse alors que
bob et charlie porte à de l'autre côté
il ya dix ans gaudord dans la caisse
comment ces lingots doivent-ils être
répartis entre alice bob et charlie et
en particulier combien de lingots alice
mérite-t-elle je vous invite à répondre
à cette question en écrivant à attirer
et un nombre par exemple si je pense que
alice mérite 4 lingots d'or je vais
écrire attiré 4 et je vous demande de
répondre avec l'intuition
ne cherchez pas à essayer de
mathématisée la chose outre mesure elle
jouait encore trois secondes pour mettre
pause 2-1 intuitivement osaka liste
mérite plus de lingots d'or que bob est
charlie parce qu'elle a un tweet ivement
plus travailler sauf que mesurer la
quantité de travail de quelqu'un c'est
pas facile
comment comparer la quantité de travail
est un caissier qui a travaillé toute la
journée à celle d'un mathématicien qui a
passé la journée à dormir mais qui au
moment de se réveiller a découvert la
preuve de son théorème particulier ni le
nombre d'heures de travail ni même la
souffrance endurée au travail ne semble
être une bonne métriques
guy m'a peut-être faire en 15 minutes de
ce que michael a fait en trois heures et
michael a peut-être trouvé son travail
immensément laborieux mais peut-on alors
vraiment dire que michael a plus
travaillé que jim pas évident plutôt que
de s'intéresser aux quantités de travail
le mathématicien économiste lloyd
chapelet c'est plutôt intéressé à la
notion de contribution
michael en trois heures et dimanche 15
minutes ont effectué la même
contribution selon chapelât il mérite
donc la même compensation
alors comment est-ce que ça s'applique à
alice bob et charlie de façon naïve on
pourrait se dire que sans alice bob et
charlie n'aurait pas su ramener la
caisse alors que le sens bob alice et
charlie aurait ramené la caisse et sans
charlie alice et bob aurait ramené la
caisse du coup si on continue ce
raisonnement naïve seul alice a eu une
contribution décisive est donc seule
elle devra récupérer les lingots de la
caisse mais je sais pas vous j'ai un
tweet your man pas l'impression que
cette redistribution soit satisfaisante
notamment parce que s'il pensait que les
lingots seraient redistribuées ainsi
bob ni charlie n'aurait accepté d'aider
à l'iss en premier lieu et puis si elle
est égaux cher et qu'elle venait
contribué à son tour
alors ni bolt ni charlie ni alice ni eve
n'aura eu de contribution décisive en
fait le concept pertinent qui a su
identifier l'homme chapelet c'est la
contribution de chacun à différents
sous-ensemble de travailleurs autrement
dit au lieu de se restreindre à la
contribution d'un individu lorsqu'il
vient aider tous les autres chats pelés
s'est intéressé à ce que l'individu
aurait contribué qu'il n'y avait qu'un
sous-ensemble des autres qui avaient
travaillé dans notre cas si on étudie
les contributions de bob on voit que
s'il est tout seul alors il sera
incapable de ramener la caisse
donc cette contribution sera nul s'ils
collaborent uniquement avec charlie
alors sa contribution demeure nul
puisque bob soit là ou non la caisse
d'epa ramener mais si maintenant alice
arrive et si bob vient l'aider alors
grâce à bob alice et bob peuvent ramener
la caisse
la contribution de bob à alice est donc
égale à tout le contenu de la caisse
à savoir 10 lingots d'or enfin si alice
et charlie travaillent tous les deux
alors la présence de bob n'apporte
aucune contribution puisque alice et
chari ensemble aurait déjà pu ramener la
caisse les contributions de charlie aux
différentes présence imaginables des
autres sont similaires
enfin alice quant à elle à une
contribution de 10 lingots d'or
donc tous les cas sauf celui où elle est
seule puisque sans alice rien et ramener
et pourvu que bob ou charlie travail
alors lady lingots d'or seront bel et
bien ramener ce tableau avec toutes les
contributions marginale des différents
travailleurs à des sous-ensembles
d'autres travailleurs et en gros ce que
l'ocha plaît à appeler la fonction
caractéristiques de coopération et pour
chapelet la redistribution
méritocratique j'étais richesse doit
dépendre uniquement de cette fonction
caractéristiques alors le génie de
chapet c'est d'avoir proposé deux
approches différentes pour déterminer
cette redistribution méritocratique et
d'avoir démontré que ces deux approches
étaient en fait équivalente
la première c'est une équation sur
laquelle je reviendrai plus tard et la
seconde que je trouve absolument
fascinante c'est une approche
axiomatique un peu comme celle de vins
nominés morgenstern
on a parlé dans l'épisode 12 en
particulier chapelet a listé quatre
propriétés désirable de la
redistribution méritocratique la
première c'est l'absence de gâchis tu es
tout bêtement dire qu'on ne va rien
jeter à la poubelle alors c'est pas
vraiment une notion méritocratique mais
je pense qu'on est d'accord pour dire
que c'est une propriété désirable
la seconde c'est la symétrie entre
contributeurs ce que ça dit c'est que si
des eaux contributeurs ont la même
contribution à chaque sous-ensemble de
travailleurs alors ils doivent recevoir
la même récompense notre cas les
contributions de bob et charly sont les
mêmes du coup ils doivent recevoir la
même chose à la fin ça paraît être un
peu le b à ba de la méritocratie la
troisième propriété c'est celle du
contributeur nul
elle dit qu un individu qui n'a aucune
contribution ne doit rien recevoir
là encore ça paraît être un principe
méritocratique raisonnable si quelqu'un
ne contribuent rien on a envie de dire
qu'ils ne méritent rien et attention
j'insiste bien sur l'aspect
méritocratique de cette définition
particuliers en dissipant en train de
parler d'égalité ou d'empathie
prévention on peut se demander si la
méritocratie c'est bien mais c'est pas
le débat aujourd'hui
enfin la quatrième propriété qui a
avancé chapelet c'est la linéarité ses
propriétés elle est un petit peu plus
technique et un petit peu moins
philosophie est liée en gros que si l'on
fait deux coopération différentes alors
la redistribution que l'on obtient si on
considère que ces deux coopération font
partie d'un super projet doit être la
même que si on considère que ces deux
projets sont distincts et qu'on effectue
les redistributions de façon séparée
bref on a quatre propriétés assez
naturel et qui semble vraiment
méritocratique est bien de façon
étonnante chapelet a démontré qu'il
existait une et une seule redistribution
des richesses qui satisfasse ces quatre
propriétés cette redistribution est ce
que l'on appelle la valeur du chapelet
et chapelet a aussi déterminé une
formule qui permet de calculer cette
valeur de chapelets la redistribution
méritocratique de chapelet est une
moyenne pondérée de ses contributions
aux différents sous groupes de
travailleurs alors il ya une petite
technicalité qui est que le poids d'une
certaine contribution est une fonction
de la taille du sous-ensemble de
contributeurs auquel ont contribué
et ça ça fait appel à ce qu'on appelle
les coefficients binôme you je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail -au
notamment parce qu'il ya une façon plus
simple de réinterpréter l'équation de
chapelets imaginons que les
contributeurs arrivent un à un mais dans
un ordre aléatoire
par exemple supposons que bob arrive
avant charlie qui arrive avant alice
on peut alors calculer la contribution
de chacun au moment où il se met à
travailler avant bob rien a récolté
puisqu'il n'y a personne pour amener la
caisse bob seul ne peut pas ramener la
caisse non plus donc sa contribution est
nul
quand charlie arrive la caisse ne peut
toujours pas être ramenés puisqu'il faut
un gaucher la contribution de charlie
est nul mais quand alice arrive
la caisse peut enfin être ramené la
contribution d'alice pour cet ordre
d'arrivée est égal à 10 lingots d'or
supposons maintenant que l'ordre
d'arrivée soit alice charlie bob alors
alice ne contribuent rien charlie
contribuer dit lingots d'or et bob de
contribuer rien supposons qu'il soit bob
alice charlie alors bob ne contribuent
rien alice contribuer 10 et charlie ne
contribuent rien et bien la valeur de
chapelets d'alice sera sa contribution
moyenne lorsque l'ordre d'arrivée des
contributeurs et aléatoire dans notre
cas on peut voir calice contribuera 10
si et seulement si elle n'est pas la
première arrivée et contribuera 06 non
or elle a une probabilité 2 sur 3 de ne
pas arriver première sa contribution
moyenne qui est aussi sa valeur de
chapelets et donc dix fois deux tiers
qui est égale à environ 6,7 lingots d'or
al'inverse bob ne contribuera disent que
si alice arrive avant et si bob arrive
avant charlie autrement dit bob ne
contribue que si l'ordre d'arrivée et
alice bob charlie ce qui a une chance
sur six d'arrivée la contribution
moyenne de bob et donc de 10 6e qui est
à peu près égale à 1,7 lingots d'or
de même la contribution moyenne de
charlie est aussi 1,7 lingots d'or
alors je ne suis pas en train de dire
qu'il faut absolument utiliser un verre
de chapelet en pratique
mais il faut bien voir que si on
n'utilise pas la valeur de chapelets
alors nécessairement il ya au moins une
des quatre propriétés que l'on a listé
précédemment
il ne sera pas satisfaite valeur de
chapelet à la can des bonnes propriétés
ceci étant dit à l'instar de nombreux
concepts dont on apparaît dans cette
série la valeur de chapelet a aussi des
faiblesses
on peut notamment signalé le fait qu'on
a su poser ici qu'il n'y avait qu'un
seul bien se partager à savoir l'or or
en pratique tout ne peut pas toujours
sera mené à de l'argent notamment parce
que chacun d'entre nous diffère dans la
manière dont on compare les loisirs à
l'argent en pratique a plutôt des biens
hétérogènes à partager et là on tombe
dans le cadre du partage du gâteau
en parlant de gâteaux justement la
valeur de chapelets suppose que rien
n'est tombé du ciel
autrement dit à suppose qu'en l'absence
de coopération aucun bien ne sera
produit et ça en fait en pratique c'est
une hypothèse qui est de plus en plus
discutables notamment avec l'avènement
de l'automatisation
mais on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
enfin et surtout la valeur de chapelets
ne favorise pas nécessairement la
coopération typiquement dans notre cas
bob a tout intérêt à exclure charlie du
deal et s'arranger avec alice pour
qu'ils n'aillent récupérer la cascadeuse
en lui promettant au passage peut-être
lui lingots plutôt que 6,7
auquel cas bob pourra mettre de lingots
dans sa poche et de façon cruciale en
excluant charlie du deal bob garantit le
fait qu à la fois alice et lui y gagne
au change en fait le bon concept pour
étudier la stabilité des coopérations
kinnock intimement liée à la notion de
contrat et le concept de corps le corps
c'est l'ensemble des redistribution des
richesses telle qu'aucun sous-ensemble
de contributeurs n'ait intérêt à sortir
de la coopération globale pour ne
coopérez qu'entre dans notre cas la
valeur de chapelets n'est pas dans le
corps puisque alice et bob ont intérêt à
sortir de la coopération globale pour ne
coopérez contre eux malheureusement le
grand drame de la théorie des jeux
coopérative c'est à dire la partie de la
théorie des jeux qui étudie les
coopérations c'est que bien souvent le
corps évident parce que les gains d'une
coopération globale ne sont pas
suffisants pour empêcher certains d'en
sortir et ça c'est typiquement le cas de
notre exemple quelle que soit la
redistribution méritocratique il ya fort
à parier que bob ou charlie finira par
se faire exclure du deal la lymphe on a
parlé du partage de gâteau et gwendoline
françois nous demandent pourquoi ne pas
avoir fait était pas en forme de cercle
pour que chacun ait un peu de tout on
peut du coup faire en sorte que chacun
est exactement
paré ensuite autorisé le libre échange
autrement dit on part d'une solution
égalitaire et ensuite on libéralise le
marché ça c'est quelque chose dont
j'avais parlé dans l'épisode 21
puisqu'on a la bonne progrès que le
partage proportionnellement juste et
stable par libéralisation du marché
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas du
partage sans jalousie
on peut partir d'un partage égalitaire
permettre le libre échange et à la faune
obtenir un partage qui est avec jalousie
donc ça c'est pas tip top pour ça
l'autre problème c'est qu'en fait le
modèle qui est souvent étudiée en
partage le gâteau c'est le cas où le
gâteau est juste un segment de droite et
on a juste le droit de le couper comme
ça la verticale oui bien sûr on fait des
maths et ce qui nous intéresse ce sont
des exemples ultra simplifié et dans ce
cadre les efforts individuels sont soit
des mesures de probabilité la partie
technique où soit on peut considérer
qu'il y à un algorithme un chacun il
réagit comme un algorithme qui est
capable si on lui donne deux barres de
savoir laquelle est sa préférée et qui
est également capable de couper le
segment en parcs qui sont égales selon
lui vous voyez bien qu'avec ce
formalisme plus générale bah c'est pas
facile de faire d'un partage égalité en
fait c'est même très très très difficile
et même impossible d'avoir un partage
égalitaire dans le cas général john 1 le
marston nous fait remarquer que en fait
ça ressemble pas mal aux enchères au
final en effet si on prend le coup du
couteau qui bouge ça ressemble
finalement beaucoup à l'enchère à la
néerlandaise quelque chose qui bouge et
puis dès que quelqu'un se dit c'est bon
il obtient le bien al'inverse le dernier
réducteur correspond un peu plus à
l'enchère un peu à la japonaise s'est
montré plutôt calé dans l'autre sens si
on fait par pas discrets comme ça ça
correspond plus à une enchère un tour
classique et la méthode des marqueurs
ressemble vraiment à l enchère un tour
mais caché mais où chacun annonce
uniquement un prix et ce prix est dans
une enveloppe et ils sont fiers cacher
anthony lequel nous nous demandons si
l'enchère caché avec redistribution des
surplus se ressemblent vcg c'est pas
tout à fait pareil hein c'est peu c'est
pas ce même assez différent en
particulier vcg à la bonne propriété
d'être une sent-il compatibles c'est ce
qui fait que les théoriciens des jeunes
adorent les cg mais vcg ne permet pas de
garantir le partage proportionnellement
juste et les propriétés de bcg sont pas
être très différente de celle de
l'enchère caché avec redistribution du
surplus si vous êtes avec des gens cool
qui vont plutôt honnête de base qui
aiment les quitter alors je vous
conseille l'enchère cacher les creux
discussions durent plus mais si vous
êtes avec des gens donc suspecté qui
sont prêt à mentir pour avoir maximum de
trucs et que tout ce qui compte pour
vous c'est l'optimalité social vous
moquer complètement des notions d'équité
alors je conseille plutôt vcg marc baget
nous fait remarquer que dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen en fait dans le premier article
il ya seconde phrase dans ce premier
article qui dit que distinctions
sociales ne peuvent être fondées que sur
l'utilité commune et ça en particulier
ça permet de justifier le fait que dans
le bus les personnes âgées ont la
priorité pour certaines places assises
ceci dit cette seconde phrase du premier
article est quand même souvent
oubliée et du coup les gens retiennent
souvent je trouve être trop souvent le
fait que ce qui remonte c'est l'égalité
avant tout est donc un point sur lequel
je voulais vraiment insister dans les
vidéos précédentes et j'en profite pour
insister à nouveau dessus dans cette
vidéo c'est que l'égalitarisme a
également ses propres difficultés et qui
sait pas forcément la solution à tout ça
ne veut pas dire non plus que cette
seconde phrase de l'article 1 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen résout tout parce que déjà la
notion d'utilité commune est une notion
extrêmement difficile et jours à
l'occasion d'y revenir dans une
prochaine vidéo
sébastien herbreteau nous demandent
pourquoi pas à maximiser le produit d
utilité c'est une question très
intéressante puisque notamment john nash
y avait pensé et il a défini notamment
le cas où essaie toujours de maximiser
la multiplication des utilités les
bonheurs des différentes personnes et
lorsqu'à que deux joueurs ça conduit à
la solution d'une âge par gaming de
négociation de nash et bien sûr ça ça
peut être très facilement généralisé ou
cawi plus de joueurs et il ya des
articles de recherche qui vont étudier
cela notamment au papier qui s'appelle
the price of lyonnaise par bercy masse
et d'autres arts ya quand même une
petite limite à cette notion de
maximisation du produit d utilité des
gens qui est le fait qu'elle dépend
fortement du statu quo si on considère
que le statu quo du partage du gâteau et
le partage égalitaire ou si on considère
que le statu quo c'est le cas où
personne n'a aucune part de gâteau on
obtient des partages différent du gâteau
lorsqu'on cherche à maximiser ce produit
d utilité est d'ailleurs nash un peu
comme j'appelais à prouver que la
solution d'une âge par gaming est la
seule façon de satisfaire quatre
propriétés qui se considéraient
érable que lorsque statu quo a vraiment
poids important dans les prises de
décision le nash bargaining est sans
doute très pertinents mais quand on ne
sait pas trop comment définir le statut
quo ça c'est une notion qui pose un
petit peu problème et c'est pour ça que
personnellement je ne suis pas un énorme
fan de cette solution même si akon de
très bonnes propriétés
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
cette vidéo clos un peu nous série de
vidéos on était un petit peu plus sur
des aspects mathématiques durée théorie
des jeux à partir de la prochaine vidéo
on va revenir sur des notions un peu
plus proche de la politique notamment
plus philosophique plus moraux en
particulier la prochaine fois on va
parler du libre arbitre
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le leak et à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ancrer futurs
épisodes
merci aux ti peur pour leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois l'entreprise qui s'impose sur un
marché est celle qui a su répondre au
mieux aux attentes de la société
c'est donc la plus méritante
malheureusement la réalité est assez
éloigné de cette utopie capitaliste g